um you mentioned how this uh this 2B
three-part series TMZ investigates TMZ
presents yeah UFO Revolution you said
that that it gave a personal yeah kind
of glimpse into your life yeah and I saw
on there that you described how uh
UFO uh it's it's more of a hobby for you
that it's that that you have a job
your job isn't about
UFOs yes I mean I it's not a hobby it's
an obsession I'm an addict for UFOs like
you now uh but it yeah so I think that
is one of the things it it reveals in
the show and again I have to watch the
Final Cut but yeah I mean I have put
more money and time and just you know
energy into investigating this topic
then I'll ever get back out from it um
yeah I do have a job I'm self-employed
but I mean look I've been self-employed
since I was you know 16 years old you
know doing Jiu-Jitsu and that kind of
thing and then all the way up through uh
I mean I polishing silver and painting
the braces off of my enemies and their
zits when you didn't have Photoshop and
I was working in a photo lab in a
basement for Sumer to buy a Mustang but
uh my whole life I've been self-employed
so my wife and I got into real estate
the smartest thing I ever did was listen
to her but also invest what I earned all
those years of training Jiu-Jitsu and
teaching Jiu-Jitsu into property so I
guess they revealed that a little bit in
the episode that yeah this is not like
how I put food on my table right you
said you're out more money than you put
in yeah I mean look I it's hard for
people to grasp if they've never made a
documentary in the way in which I do but
like I don't get paid to come on these
interviews I I don't get paid to do news
hits um my films some the bobazar film
took me legitimately nine years so
imagine all that time and it it's you
know once we started filming for that
that's a whole another thing that was
rapid Pace but all the trips all the
work getting to know people moving that
on yeah I'll never recover all of that
uh I'm not complaining that's just how
it is so I think that's important for
people to understand that you know I do
this because I love it and because I
want to understand more and I I'm greedy
I'm selfish I want to know more more
than I want to tell other people so
that's been my focus for from you know a
long time now and so there's stuff that
you haven't gotten out and that it's
come it came out in this UF UFO
Revolution couple things have come out
in this yeah what I haven't gotten out I
just haven't gotten out yet but yeah we
got two new or three new major assets I
call them products so military filmed
UFO footage or imagery and in this
series you know I my priority is to
protect prot sources even if they don't
protect themselves and that is that is a
a delicate dance in this series I was
able to release uh two very important
UFO
cases how do you know that they're
actual military couldn't you photoshop
like crosshairs and yeah sure you could
switch it to Thermal to not but like do
you have a some sort of a a way to Suess
that out yeah why did it take me three
and a half years to feel Cal confident
putting this out to the public because
yeah I'm fastidious is the word someone
just taught me with my work I don't know
what it means it basically means like
attention to detail but like yeah man uh
you could fake anything these days and
that's the problem right you could fake
any footage so I usually and typically
require about three times that I get a
piece of footage and I get it
anonymously and I set it up that way I
don't want a source that I'm talking
with I don't want to know who gave me
video that's a legal issue so I they it
to me does that not uh call into
question The credibility if you don't I
mean you know the swords you're just not
going to share the sords so but it's not
a source see that's the thing what I'm
saying is uh it takes usually about
three times for me to get a product
right like a military filmed video then
what I do is through my own channels not
through connections that sources give me
I I mean I have sources in the dod the
doj the CIA the FBI I mean you name it
and I'm not bragging I'm I'm actually
making a threat right now I I I I I no
no because here's the deal here's the
deal I'll know if there's [__] and so
any engagement I've ever had with
agencies they know too that I will know
if there's [__] I'll find out if
there's an active investigation of
course there are active investigations
into what George nap and I have released
and good for them it's an important job
the idea that if people leak stuff you
got to plug those leaks I get it but as
a journalist the First Amendment the
idea of freedom of press for public good
so I feel maybe I'm ignorant but I feel
protected because everybody I've ever
talked to in agencies their biggest fear
is that other countries will compromise
will blackmail so they can get [__]
before I vetted it for National Security
I've never done nothing wrong so the
whole idea is when you get this stuff
how do you vet it how do you know how do
you know it's not fake there's a lot of
ways to do that but here's what I tell
people first conversation if you're a
source and you call me I say have
patience on me don't give up on me I'm
on Cosmic time not on your time
seriously and I develop relationships
over years with people I then do my own
vetting through my own sources not
through who sources give me sources and
then I bring it to George knap when I
feel it's a good case and he does his
own process through his own contacts
that he's made for over 40 years if I
put something out you can bet your
[__] ass that it is legit and that it
is worth putting out to the public for
debate very cool um when you sent me the
trailer for The the 2B three-part
series um there's kind of a lot of
emphasis on people being in danger
people's lives being threatened people
David gush that right and the last time
we spoke to you uh you seemed pretty
laidback about about the whole idea of
being a Target being in danger you know
like um um in the in the series itself
you you said that you're safe because
you're a journalist do you still feel
that way if you remember specifically
what I told you is that I use that term
as a shield you know I'm a journalist
because I say I am because I break news
because I bring stuff forward I don't
know the letter of the law but I know
the spirit of the law so you know look
in one sense it's a front don't [__]
with me I will push that button but on
so so I'm not minim iing that I'm not
minimizing what I have heard from
sources I'm not minimizing what they've
experienced there are active Inspector
General
complaints against what has been done to
people like David grush and it is
diabolical and it it involves physical
danger me myself everybody seems to
pretend they're my friend so the thing
is is I've never um I don't feel the
need to publicly talk about the the
pressure that I feel you know in
protecting sources and myself right I'm
not going to minimize it though this is
a secret and it's it's treated at a
level UFOs is treated at a level higher
than weapons of mass destruction meaning
that there's a threat somehow in the
mind of intelligence agencies how they
come at how they try to silence people
it can be compromising journalists like
just even on Twitter and like getting
them to like try to discredit people
character assassination which we saw
with David grush yeah with his PTSD so
[__] stupid he got over it a lot of
people [__] murder themselves because
of you know PTSD they they're so limp
dick these these kinds of things but
there's more there's other ways that
people can be pressured and other ways
it can be threatened and yeah George
knpp and I have our own stories and one
day we we will tell that and I've
documented everything but I I don't
think that's important right now what's
important is people to Have Courage how
we treat our whistleblowers
right now is going to determine what we
learn about the UFO topic within the
next year so they did show that a little
bit in the series like you said but I I
don't dwell on it man you know I feel
like if you're doing the right thing or
you're trying to you know then you're on
the right [__] path do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
sto's butt wipes for your butt Hool are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get sto's
hot sauce for your butthole plus sto's
butthole destroyer and sto's butt wipes
for your butthole it's the butthole
bundle available on Amazon right
now yeah dude